his new movie is called here today and
you can see it in theaters right now
um but from time to time on the show we
get guests with
you know stories so epic so long that
there's just not enough time to tell
them and there are some great
storytellers out there so
it just so happens that billy is one of
those guests so we now bring you another
installment of
epic story time
[Music]
that one okay with this segment i ask
one question just one and billy will
tell us an
epic story backed by a bunch of
illustrations um as always
i'll have some follow-up questions at
the end because that's who i am
uh so here's my one question billy it's
almost summer
do you like to get out this time of year
and enjoy your garden
yes i do and then uh kelly that is my
my epic story
i love that
okay it has to do with my garden um a
while ago my daughter was about to be
married
and we're gonna have a big outdoor party
at the house in the garden
so we had to resot it the whole thing is
about half an acre
so we had beautiful grass all stunning
flowers it looks sensational
then one morning it was all torn up the
beautiful sod was ripped up
plants overturned every place so we had
to redo it we put
new sod down rolls and rolls next
morning it's all rolled up we thought
it was kids in the neighborhood screwing
around or red sox fans
and so i alerted the neighborhood
security service watch the fence nothing
next day the gardens dug up again
and now there were animal prints all
over the place
and the gardener says to us you got
raccoons you have raccoons
and maybe a skunk and the the raccoons
they eat the little grub worms on the
bottom of the sod
and on the roots of the plants so one
night i'm in full tuxedo i have to host
a charity event
and i'm late and it's all the way
downtown and in my tuxedo i go to leave
in that the front door is glass and what
do i see
a big raccoon sitting right on the
welcome mat looking at me through the
glass this
raccoon was huge he looked like he was a
mascot for a team
named the raccoons that's how big he was
so i i tap on the glass
and he stands up in like a karate pose
and he goes
come on out come on out come on out mr
big shut i will bite you in the ass come
on come on out
i'm scared so i run to the back door
and he's there either that or another
one i look just like him but come on
what are the odds on that
and i go get out of here get out of here
and i had a jar that had a lot of change
in it
right so i i shook it at him and then he
just starts
laughing at me what are you doing with
your parking meter money what are you
dumb come on now so get it broom and i
go
get out of here scat scout scat scat and
he goes
this is a real pretty smart raccoon
and he says by the way mr big shot i
left you a little gift on your welcome
man
so i went to the front door and he had
pooped
on the welcome mat so now now i'm really
angry
i'm really angry so i go on the internet
to see
uh raccoon deterrence what can you do to
deter
a raccoon and they say get coyote urine
i should get kyoto and sprinkle it
around your flower beds and where you
think they're coming in
coyote urine so kelly my luck i'm out of
coyote urine
i don't know how that must have been the
holidays and
and he said well if they smell the
coyote or they get scared because
coyotes are a real predator for the
raccoon so i think if they're scared
of a coyote they'd be terrified of me
so i peed in the garden
every place i possibly could and i'm an
older man now so it took me about
45 minutes or so to get everything
covered
and there's this neighbor who lives on a
hill looking right down at me
as i'm finishing up and he's smiling and
waving
it didn't faze him at all because
apparently gary busey lived in a house
before i did
so
so nothing nothing nothing and and
the garden keeps getting torn up and and
there's always a
fresh poop right on the welcome mat so
now i'm talking to a friend i said i got
this
raccoon problem and he goes wait i got a
guy i got a guy
the guy they talk about everybody is a
guy named trapper joe
and he humanely captures them and then
releases them in the wild so trapper joe
comes over to the house
i meet him and he insists on being
called trapper joe when you talk to him
so now i feel like i'm in a kitty show
or something i think we'll catch
anything trapper joe
well i sure hope so bill i sure hope so
and now he's sniffing around the garden
and he sniffs around the flower beds and
he looks at me and goes
did you pee in a garden and i
i couldn't lie i said my my wife did
my wife did so then he brings out three
cages
right and he puts the cages down one of
them is covered in a black
hefty bag in case he catches a skunk
because if you catch a skunk you don't
want them to spray because that spray
smells worse than anything you can
possibly imagine
and he bakes them with sardines and
that's it and he leaves
and now the morning comes and kelly to
me it's like it's like christmas morning
what did i get what did i get did i get
anything and i look out in the garden
and the door
of the one with the black hefty bag is
shut there's something in the cage
so i tiptoe out there and i would like
to take my broom with me and i touched
the cage and it starts shaking like this
and i start screaming like a
four-year-old girl like is there
something in the cage there's something
in the cage there's something to be
kidding
so i'm called trapper joe what is it
there's something in the cage
so trapper joe comes over and he's like
dressed in riot gear
and he opens up the door reaches in with
a sick leather glove
and he pulls out frisky our neighbor's
cats
oh my gosh all that trouble so for the
first three days
we caught frisky twice a blue bird
and one of the smaller gardeners who
apparently loves sardines
and the garden keep getting torn up tone
up and then one day
about two days later i go out in the
morning and they're in the cage
is a small raccoon and then in another
cage
is the big raccoon the one that taunted
me so trapper joe comes he takes him
puts him in the back of his pickup truck
so the big guy looks like some criminal
that the cops are taking away the
backseat of the car
he takes it about 45 minutes outside of
la
into the into the hills and he releases
them
and he videos them so you make sure that
they weren't harmed and they run away
and the big ones
stops turns around and gives them the
finger
i want that picture and
now it's been it's been a long time and
we haven't had any problems
you know in the garden the only problem
is we still don't know who's pooping on
a welcome mat
so that's
[Laughter]
[Applause]
his new movie is called here today and
you can see it in theaters now
and thanks to marcel and our art
department for those great illustrations
oh my god he's incredible yep i'm still
here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help